this is the moment police raided jeffrey
epstein's palm beach mansion unsure what
they were going to find
behind closed doors here prosecutors say
epstein and glenn maxwell were
committing horrifying crimes her
presence in this house is obvious and in
their closing argument prosecutors said
ms maxwell was in on the whole thing
this picture they say shows two sexual
predators
while epstein's motivation was sexual
gratification maxwell's they say was
money
prosecutors claim she was serving up
teenagers for epstein to abuse in return
for this life of luxury
four of glenn maxwell's siblings arrived
at court together for the final day of
this trial
prosecution lawyer alison moe said
maxwell ran the same playbook again and
again she groomed them she caused deep
and lasting harm to young girls it's
time to hold her accountable
annie farmer's experience at epstein's
new mexico ranch prosecutors said was
typical of his and glenn maxwell's
abusing this picture of her at her high
school prom was taken the same month as
that trip when she says maxwell gave her
a sexual massage
her teenage diaries in which she writes
about being weirded out by epstein's
behavior evidence says the government of
classic grooming techniques to which
maxwell was an accomplice
laura meninger delivered the rebuttal
for the defence she said these accusers
had stories to tell about jeffrey
epstein and decades later they inserted
gulen maxwell they each filed a civil
suit and they took home millions but
their stories have changed dramatically
over time
if the verdict arrives in the next two
days and she is found guilty gulen
maxwell will spend her 60th birthday on
christmas day in prison and very
possibly the rest of her life